I went to VidCon last week thanks agreed
and then this week I've had audition
after audition after audition it's like
4 p.m. on Sunday and I don't have enough
time to make a video but I didn't wanna
leave you hanging
cuz come on let's face it I mean you're
awesome oh speaking of VidCon I I was
looking for a Hank green to say thank
you and I couldn't find him anywhere but
I did see John Green and so you know I
had this whole speech rehearsed in my
head I was like I'm gonna go up to him
and be like hey John Green my name is
Anna and I just want to say thank you so
much for looking for Alaska really
helped me deal with the death of my
sister and I'm really looking forward to
reading future works of yours it was
great it was classy in my mind I was
just like suave and a slob and of course
like mutton life never plays out that
fuckin way so I go over to John Green
but he's in the drama conversation so
I'm standing by like a total weirdo
someone comes up and says Oh Johnny
you'd be somewhere so he's starting to
move away I'm like oh no I thought he
looks back and I'm like this is my
chance so I just give up and he's like
oh sorry John Green sorry that I didn't
do well did I ever tell you about the
time I almost died or at least I thought
I was gonna die I got into surprise
surprise a horrible car crash the car
accident was my fault
the car had stopped at a red light and I
hit him going 50 miles an hour and I saw
them at the last second and I was like
this is it I'm gonna die so I just
gripped the steering wheel and closed my
eyes I slam on the brake but in that
moment when I thought I was gonna die I
don't really at peace like well it was a
good run Anna so long and they say that
your life flashes before your eyes total
bullshit it does not I was just hoping
that I didn't pee and they didn't find
me with like pee all over my body last
thoughts by then another cup hope I
don't pee stay awesome Gotham